vamos a tratar de descubrir cuánto es 87
y podemos imaginar que estos son 8
tomates y le vamos a sumar 7 moras
azules y la pregunta sería cuántas
piezas de fruta tenemos en total los
invito a que pausa en este vídeo y
traten de resolver esto ustedes mismos
ok asumo que hicieron el intento de
resolverlo
así que continuemos la manera en que voy
a resolver esto es poniendo tomates para
tratar de llenar mi primer paquete de 10
frutas y luego voy a seguir sumando
frutas hasta que haya sumado 7 frutas
vamos a empezar con los tomates un
tomate dos tomates tres tomates cuatro
tomates
5 tomates
7 y 8 tomates y a estos 8 tomates les
tengo que sumar 7 moras azules
una
y voy a hacer una pausa aquí porque
termine de juntar un grupo de 10 frutas
todavía tengo que sumar más moras azules
porque solamente he sumado 2 pero
sumando estas dos frutas completé un
grupo de 10 frutas aquí tengo un grupo
de 10 piezas de fruta esto lo puedo
representar con un 1 aquí arriba voy a
escribir 1 y sé que el resultado va a
ser un número de dos dígitos y el dígito
de la izquierda es un 1 pero tengo que
seguir sumando moras azules porque
solamente he sumado 2 así que sigo
sumando 3 moras azules 4 moras azules 5
y siete moras azules entonces tengo un
grupo de diez y tengo más piezas de
fruta todavía este grupo de diez lo
puedo representar con un 1 este
resultado va a ser un número de dos
dígitos y este es el dígito de la
izquierda y está en la posición de las
decenas o sea un grupo de diez y aquí
voy a escribir decenas
y luego vamos a ver cuántas piezas más
tengo las voy a agrupar y tengo 5 piezas
más estas son cinco unidades más tengo
en total una decena y cinco unidades más
estas son unidades
cuanto es 87 15 y solo para recordar lo
que el número 15 representa este una
representa una decena y aquí escribo una
decena y el 5 representa 5 unidades y
aquí ponemos 5 unidades y otra manera de
escribir esto es una decena es igual a
10 y 5 unidades es igual a 5 así que 8 +
7 es igual a 15 que es lo que nos
interesaba resolver en este vídeo pero
también tenemos que pensar en lo que
este número 15 representa y 15 es igual
a una decena y 5 unidades o lo que es lo
mismo 10 5